now a convicted murderer and rapist has
been sentenced to life imprisonment
today in what is the oldest Double
Jeopardy case in England Dennis mcgrory
was 28 when he sexually assaulted
stabbed and strangled 15 year old Jackie
Montgomery in her home in North London
back in 1975. he was initially acquitted
but was later found guilty after a swab
from her body was retested and showed a
match with his DNA
Jackie Montgomery was raped and murdered
on the 2nd of June 1975 in her North
London home the next day Dennis mcgrory
was arrested he had a bruised lip a long
scratch to his neck and smaller
scratches to his wrist and arm which he
claimed were caused when he was
assaulted by a group
he was charged with her murder on the
10th of July he went on trial the
following year however he was acquitted
after the judge ruled there was
insufficient evidence for a conviction
but in November 2015 at the request of
Jackie's family the Metropolitan Police
began a review of the case and
resubmitted a swamp that had been taken
from Jackie's body back in 1975.
having found a DNA match from the swab
Dennis mcgrory was arrested and charged
in March 2020 he went on trial at the
Old Bailey in March 2022 he was
convicted of rape and murder during a
second trial at Huntington Crown Court
on the 19th of December 2022.
you attended one more nine offered road
that night
clear that there was a violent struggle
between you and Jackie
as I've already noted Furniture was
turned over the phone was off the hook
and there was a pulled lock of hair
violent struggle you raped Jackie and
your violence culminated in you
murdering her literally stabbing her to
death
we can go live now to Huntington Sky's
Emma birchley who is now outside the
court for us Justice served Emma nearly
50 years after the death of teenager
Jackie Montgomery really down to the
change in the law back in 2003 that
permitted a retrial
yes changes in the law so the change to
the Double Jeopardy legal principle that
was overthrown in 2003 so it meant that
mcgrory Dennis mcgrory could face the
same charge once more but not only that
another crucial factor is the
Improvement in science the DNA test that
could be done on the swabs which are
taken at the time and thankfully were
kept for all those decades and which
proved a billion to one match with
mcgrory at the time there was a trial in
1976 that the judge through that case
out of court at the old bayley because
he said the evidence was circumstantial
so that DNA evidence really changed this
case but it was a really horrific crime
that this 15 year old girl went through
protecting her aunts so mcgrory had gone
there air wild with rage wanting the
information about where his ex-partner
Jackie's on lived and she in stopping
giving that information trying to
prevent that happening was burnt on the
legs she was stabbed in the back the
knife puncturing her heart her stomach
and her liver and she had the flex of an
iron around her neck and he denied that
crime for all those years but of course
now finally in a trial here ending last
month he was found guilty both of rape
and murder a really long wait for the
family and after the sentencing today
which saw mcgrory given 26 years in jail
of which he will serve a minimum of 25
years and 126 days we heard from
Jackie's family her older sister Kathy
Montgomery this is what she had to say
she suffered that girl you know she was
a little girl you know she's suffering
she didn't deserve what she got but he
deserved what he got just now that
reflected you know that reflected it how
hard has it been for you knowing that
he's been out for decades so so
destroying
Soldier strong no enough couldn't do
nothing to you know nothing to get near
him and we all know he's done it since
day one
appeared by a video link with a mask
over his face wearing a dark sweatshirt
he was told by Mr Justice Brian that in
the decades that followed you must have
thought you got away with the heinous
crimes and he added you have not shown
one iota of remorse for what you have
done